[Music]
branch we got attacked by a Bergen it
took everybody what's your plan rescue
everyone to make it home safely
so you're going to scrapbook them to
freedom solid burn branch
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
he who controls the trolls controlled
the kingdom
I am back pain you're a dude oh snap
so happy I could just scream ah ah
what's wrong nothing I thought we were
celebrating that's your happy shelf
this bumper what's your plan to rescue
everyone to make it home safely
so you're going to scrapbook them to
freedom
solid burn branch
[Music]
I
Oh may i Oh three words
trolls
[Music]
you are fantastic pretty PG so one of
these tunnels leads to the troll tree
that's right so many of them I wonder
which one I don't know
choose a hole Y Z for one Moony to
Bergen town and the others mm down who
said that
me hey guys how's it going I just wanted
to warn you one of these tunnels leads
to the troll tree and the others to
certain death death death does do you
think you can tell us which is the right
one
you bet great no that's okay we're fine
thanks branch if he's trying to help us
I don't like the looks of him he seems
to know what he's talking about
okay fine which way do we go first you
have to give me a high five then I'll
tell you I don't do high fives slap it
boss not gonna happen here just do this
but with your hand thank you for that
demonstration really cleared up exactly
what I will not be doing rich it's a
high five the others lead to certain
death get perspective all right
no let you slide with a fist bump whoo
shark attack no no no no jellyfish pants
amateur Keys Snowman Dolphin helicopter
that's upper monkey to zoo what's your
shift
[Music]
okay okay okay now I'm thinking we hug
[Music]
star shining bright above really
seriously more singing yes seriously
singing helps me relax maybe you ought
to try it I don't sing and I don't relax
this is the way I am and I like it
I also like a little silence hello
darkness my old friend I've come to talk
with you again because a vision softly
creeping
it's seeds while I was sleeping
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
may I
you have to sing I'm in a good mood do
you have to be in a good mood why
wouldn't I be by this time tomorrow I'll
be with all my friends oh I wonder what
they're doing right now
Oh probably being digested they're a
live branch you know it you don't know
anything papi and I can't wait to see
the look on your face when you realize
the world isn't all cupcakes and
rainbows cuz it isn't hey I know it's
not all cupcakes and rainbows but I'd
rather go through life thinking that it
mostly is instead of being like you you
don't sing you don't dance so gray all
the time what happened to you a Birkin
maybe there's no bergen is there you
just said that so I stopped talking
maybe
hi i'm anna kendrick and i'm justin
timberlake beat poppy is the happiest
troll of all the trolls how do you
always talk on the bright side and
branches the opposite i don't do high
five slap at boss nope little slappy
make daddy happy fine too slow
oh snap this is the story about
happiness topic how far some would go to
get it how far we went to get it back
what's your plan arrest whoever you want
to make it home safely so you're going
to scrapbook them to freedom solid burn
branch it's so wonderful to get to voice
these characters and I think music adds
so much to animation it just feels like
they belong together
the bergens gather the trolls that
they've caught and it's the music that
rescues them you at the same
eyes don't be discouraged oh I realize
it's hard to take courage in a world
full of people you can lose sight of it
all the darkness inside you
can make you feel so small and I see
you're the creators of Shrek invite you
on a musical adventure yeah that proves
one voice can change the world happiness
is inside of all of us sometimes we just
need someone to help you find it
DreamWorks trolls
come
beautiful
now they can we hug find your happy
place November 4th
[Music]
my name is branch and I'm a troll why do
I live in a heavily fortified survival
bunker because right outside my door
lurks a nightmare
named poppy poppy is the leader of the
trolls and it's not her fault she's so
insanely happy she's just never faced a
real problem until now cupcake branch we
just got attacked by a Bergen it took
everybody what's your plan to rescue
everyone to make it home safely so
you're going to scrapbook them to
freedom solid burn branch
I got the Spanish and stahma bones it
goes electric I only turn it on yeah I
got that sunshine in my pocket you got
that good soul in my beat Phil that
happen in my day this your shift
[Music]
phone
so just
so kid
may I oh snap
DreamWorks trolls
[Music]
this is where we rebuild our
civilization
it has everything we need
plain water has wick acoustic acoustic
meet the clothes they sing they dance
and have lots of fun
[Music]
but these creatures aren't just
delightful
[Music]
whoa they're delicious
oh my god DreamWorks trolls I got this
feeling in sky my bones
it goes electric baby when I turn it on
I got that sunshine in my pocket you got
that kosoul my feet feel that happen in
my pocket it drops from everything goes
[Music]
but you for you
Oh
we facility this
[Music]
oh snap
you
I love you brother it's like we're best
friends that live together positive mom
dad I'm excited I want a baby brother
dear stork delivery service